hey there guys and welcome to the bio
near the home of action performance and
technology if you're interested in
improving your mind and your body
through training and technology then
you're in the right place and if you're
interested in improving your lifestyle
and living a life that's more free and
full of adventure by working online then
you're in the right place here we talk
about body building calisthenics
strength training martial arts parkour
nootropics brain training creativity
intelligence bio hacking brain
plasticity ambidexterity synesthesia
working online technology vr
transhumanism if that all sounds cool
then stay tuned because there's a ton of
content on this site I delve into some
topics that I think other people don't
really touch on I'm really highly
inspired by action games Marvel movies
and most open comics anime
I love seeing characters that push
themselves but get stronger and faster I
love things like flow States I'm
fascinated in crisis strength I want to
know how to jump high out and run faster
how to punch harder that's why as well
as running this channel I'm also an
entrepreneur I'm someone who runs an
online business as a writer and I also
work for Android authorities a presenter
and by doing all this I've given myself
more freedom more time to pursue my real
interests hit the gym hard and try out
cool VR training technology to research
things like flow States as I say in like
brain plasticity and to try out
different nootropics to push my
productivity and my performance further
and I just found all this stuff a bit
awesome and if you find it a bit awesome
to that I'd love for you to stick around
to hit subscribe to comment down below
we have tons of great discussions some
of the best videos on this channel
include my video on flow States I have
several on those my superhero trading
videos I've talked about Black Panther
training Batman training the videos
where I look at real-life examples of
high-performing individuals like Bruce
Lee or Einstein videos about nootropics
and supplements you can use to boost
your sleep increase your energy be more
productive be more inventive videos
about cool training techniques like
weighted stretching like overcoming
isometrics or old time strongman
training I aim to do deeper research
looking at the latest theories and
studies drawing on my knowledge of
psychology and my eight years
as a health and fitness writer I delve
into underground trading methods find
new angles testing techniques try new
supplements and bio hacks anything that
can help to become healthier happier
fitter smarter or stronger
I love the searching what we're really
capable of when we've put our minds to
it because it's fascinating and for the
sheer fun of it
if you secretly wish you would go COO if
you're interested in how to hack the
mind of increase your IQ if you want to
build your own business or if you want
to increase your functional strength
then you're in the right place say
subscribe now please and I've got tons
more come to the site as well stuff on
meditation and focus stuff on a
real-life Super Soldier Serum stuff on
calisthenics and weighted calisthenics
and hand balancing if all that sounds
great then stick around and I'll see you
in the next video and of course don't
forget to check out the bio near comm
the official blog that goes with this
channel there you'll find more in-depth
posts as well as links to resources
studies and much more and of course
follow me on social media I'm on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram as the
bio near follow me on Facebook and
Twitter if you want to get updated about
new posts and follow me on instagram if
you'd like to see my workouts the
productivity the projects I'm working on
any moment I'll see you there I'll see
you here thanks a ton for stopping by
and bye for now